[Music]
hello how are you greetings sal y jaramillo
with your report of the day an accident in the
southwest of the valley left two people
hospitalized today the accident occurred
on sunday afternoon near the
streets of querer spring mount in according to
the police both drivers  They were
taken to the hospital and one of them
had serious injuries. Until
now, the exact cause of the accident is unknown.
The FBI is currently
working to return the belongings
of all the people who attended
the concert where the shooting on October 1 was recorded.
The
federal investigative agency
says hundreds of items
including cell phones, key chains, among other
emails and letters have been
sent to survivors advising them of the
process to recover their belongings,
but the FBI is asking people who
have yet to be contacted by the agency
to  contact the
residence center for more information
please see  visit our page x-none
dotcom
nevada coronavirus infections continue to decline
yesterday
15 deaths were reported but also the
state has recorded fewer tests and the
state of nevada currently ranks
last in the entire country in its plan
to distribute the
coronavirus vaccine something officials hope to
change Monday reopens the mega
vaccination site they see themselves
having which they had to close
Friday and over the weekend for
scheduled renovations and currently
the largest vaccination site in
southern nevada right
now the state is only
vaccinating
healthcare workers as well as people over
the age of 70
and las vegas will have representation in the
highly anticipated super bowl 55 game
player jon knudsen is a
crazy high school graduate  facebook train and play
for the time buccaneers team
so we send you
congratulations and best of luck ah  Now let's
go with your weather forecast,
a day with rain, breezes and
temperatures in the 40s is expected, as well as a
chance of rain and snow until
tomorrow morning. Have a good day.
I am from Jaramillo and this was x in
Spanish
[Music]